well before the Marvel Cinematic
Universe ruled the world Indy writer
director Kevin Smith was ahead of the
game with his own view asked universe
now the filmmaker is ready to take us
back there with Jay and Silent Bob
reboot if you're wondering what it's all
about we've got the answers to all your
blunt questions and keeping with Kevin
Smith's indie film roots Jay and Silent
Bob reboots will rollouts in a slightly
different manner than most major movies
do fathom events which distribute
special and live events to select
multiplexes will handle reboots first
showings on October 15th 2019 these
special screenings will include an
introduction from Smith some bonus
material and free movie posters for
lucky fans
two days later reboot will screen again
as part of a double feature alongside
Jay and Silent Bob strike back Jay and
Silent Bob only work in small doses if
at all they don't deserve their own
movie he's got a point Ken what's the
next one say after those initial events
Smith and Muse are taking the show on
the road the pair will travel around the
u.s. to personally present the film and
follow it up with Q&A sessions between
October 21st and December 12th the Jay
and Silent Bob reboot Roadshow will hit
31 cities for 45 screenings so come on
out and join us give us your money
because we got to eat this year Kevin
Smith has been doing his own thing in
the movie industry for 25 years in that
time he's built up a massive world of
characters with his view ask universe
and Jay and Silent Bob reboots is
bringing back a ton of them Jason Mewes
and Kevin Smith are back as the titular
duo while Jason Lee once again plays bro
deep roots is comics loving character
from Mallrats Joey Lauren Adams will
appear as her chasing amy comics creator
Alyssa Jones as well Ben Affleck
returning as his chasing amy character
Holden McNeil a Plex frequent
collaborator Matt Damon will also make
an appearance likely portraying Loki his
Dogma character though he's also
appeared in the franchise playing a
version of himself
it's hunting season
rosario dawson has signed on to play
becky the role she originated in clerks
2 alongside Brian O'Halloran returning
as clerks protagonist Dante it's not all
Kevin Smith veterans along for the ride
though val kilmer melissa benoist joe
manganiello justin long prague robinson
and chris hemsworth are also set to make
the leap into the askew naver's for the
first time yes Jay and Silent Bob
reboots will revisit the world of
Smith's classic 90s comedies just as
fans remember them
it's a self-aware movie making fun of
both itself and Hollywood's obsession
with retreads according to Smith
speaking at a post podcast taping Q&A in
May 2019 the movie follows what happens
when Jay and Silent Bob find out that
Hollywood is making a reboot of that old
movie that they had made about them in
Jay and Silent Bob strike back and they
have to go across the country to
Hollywood to stop it all over again
Smith is well aware of the irony of the
situation
adding the observation it's a movie that
makes fun of sequels and remakes and
reboots while being all three at the
same time along with the road trip to
stop a movie from getting made again
there's a major plot addition Jay has a
child a young woman named Millennium
Falcon Milly is a lot like her father
and that she also has a constant
companion who never speaks a deaf friend
named soapy they insist on heading to
Hollywood - on July 18th 2019 movie
distributors Saban films released the
first trailer for Jay and Silent Bob
reboots the profanity-laden preview
proves that reboot does indeed imitate
the plots of Jay and Silent Bob strike
back while also making fun of that movie
and Hollywood - Jay and Silent Bob
strike back concerns the duo's trip to
Hollywood to shudder a movie version a
Bluntman and chronic a marijuana meets
Batman style comic book created by Ben
Affleck's character Holden McNeil Jason
Biggs and james van der beek appear as
themselves as the stars of the
adaptation along the way Jay meets and
falls for an animal rights activist
named Justice played by Shannon
Elizabeth according to the Jay and
Silent Bob reboot trailer the new movie
centers on a reboot of the Bluntman and
chronic movie in production with Val
Kilmer and Melissa Benoist taking on the
roles in a winking nod to their other
jobs Biggs and Van Der Beek do return
for a cameo though
anyway Kevin Dean Smith along the way J
reconnects with justice who introduces
him to their teenage daughter played by
Harley Quinn Smith
Smith's real-life daughter Jay and
Silent Bob diehards can also get a load
of the official Jay and Silent Bob
reboot poster this winking at the past
key arts is consistent with the rest of
the movie and it's nod to the Past as
the poster depicts Jason Mewes and Kevin
Smith and character standing against the
brick wall not unlike the one they
leaned against and clerks back in 1994
Smith also unveiled a movie poster for
the movie within a movie advertising the
Bluntman and chronic reboot it strikes a
dark gritty tone reminiscent of the DC
Comics movie starring one of the view s
universe's most successful alumni fan
Affleck but Affleck was the bomb and
phantoms word phantoms like a mouth
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]